This is just genuinely terrible news.
The state of New York has decided to cancel
the Democratic presidential primary, which
they had rescheduled to June 23rd because
of Corona virus.
And you might be wondering, why is it terrible?
Either way, Joe Biden is going to be the Democratic
nominee.
It has everything to do with Donald Trump.
We already suspect that Donald Trump is likely
to try funny business in November.
We don't know exactly what the funny business
will be, but there are a number of different
things that he is likely to try.
Why would Democrats do anything that could
be seen as any kind of precedent for funny
business in November?
And I know many of you will say, listen, David,
canceling a primary when there is only one
candidate remaining is very different than
canceling or postponing a highly contested
presidential election.
And you would be correct that they are not
the same thing.
But this is Donald Trump that we're talking
about, Donald Trump, who's already been playing
up, that the Democrats are stealing it from
Bernie Sanders.
Donald Trump, who complains to this day about
an election that he won.
He says the results were wrong.
He won in 2016 electorally.
So this is something that could only embolden
Trump in opposing vote by mail in November
in who knows what other ideas Trump might
have and would be emboldened.
And now Trump can say, listen, everything's
different this time around.
Look at what Democrats did in New York.
What New York should have done is say we're
going to do the election.
One hundred percent by mail.
It'll be a 100 percent absentee ballot election.
There are two months to set this up, minus
a few days.
This can be done.
It would help to make the case that the election
in November must go on.
But by mail.
So New York is doing the exact opposite of
what they should be doing.
New York could foment the case for vote by
mail in November by doing it themselves and
saying, look, we said it, we did it, we set
it up.
We're not normally a vote by mail state, but
we were able to do it.
Instead, they are canceling an election altogether.
And you're doing two things when you do this.
Number one, you are enraging the Bernie or
Busters and there's something to be said about
that.
Although the degree to which this will impact
whether they ultimately vote for Joe Biden
in November, I don't know.
But number two, you're giving Trump something
to point to if he ends up saying, hey, let's
delay the November election.
That's it.
Trump can't do that unilaterally.
Remember, it's up to states to delay or not
delay elections.
But Trump could say, please do it or you give
Trump the opportunity to push against vote
by mail by saying, listen, if it were so easy
and logical to do vote by mail, why didn't
New York do it?
They canceled the primary.
Clearly vote by mail.
Isn't that easy to do?
So these are all very good questions and it
all gives Trump cover for funny business.
Now, I know some of you are going to write
to me and you're going to say many states
canceled Republican primaries over the virus.
The point is Trump can't really use that in
November to try to pull funny business.
A Democratic primary being canceled altogether
opens the door to be misused and abused by
Donald Trump.
Now, here's the crazy thing.
There are still going to be down ballot elections
in New York on June 23rd.
According to The New York Times, polling places
are expected to remain open in 42 counties
in New York State, four down ballot races,
and you will be able to obtain absentee ballots
to vote in those.
So much of New York state is still having
an election on June 23rd.
But they've eliminated the Democratic primary.
Obviously, Biden was going to win the New
York Democratic primary.
Obviously, the outcome of the primary overall
was not going to change with or without New
York voting.
But you're still holding an election for other
downballot races and you are giving Trump
something he can potentially use.
I think it's a very bad idea.
I think this is the wrong decision being made
by New York.
Do you disagree with me?
Let me know it